you my people
are in trouble let me help them please
i'll do whatever you say
sure was a game changer from 1986 that's
the pilot episode of star trek the next
generation featuring sir patrick stewart
as captain jean-luc picard the legendary
actor returns to that role in the
franchise series star trek picard in the
upcoming second season picard and his
crew take an exciting journey into the
past of course before he leaves picard
now a chancellor at the starfleet
academy shares some words of wisdom with
the graduates
i choose to leave you
with the words of
my mother
who was no explorer at all
when i was a boy
she would point
to the night sky and say
look up jean-luc
and let's see
what's out there
joining us right now is a living legend
one of the greatest of his generation
sir patrick stewart good morning how are
you doing
oh good morning nate i'm doing great i'm
so excited i'm sitting in a studio van
on the street outside my house i feel
like
i think actually i i feel like frank
bruni it was so interesting watching
frank talking because i feel i'm here to
report breaking news but the only
breaking news i've got is that the crows
are out in the street
yes we're holding you
we're holding your hostage
no doubt from a spaceship to a van on
the street um
let's let's talk about this second
season though you said that star trek
picard is it's going to be unique and
unexpected in this second season how so
well we have elements in picard which we
didn't have in next generation um i
could drop you a little hint by saying
from jean-luc's point of view they might
be somewhat romantic
which
i have enjoyed very much indeed but i i
also have a new crew
and that's an extraordinary group of
actors that we have that have made the
uh the experience coming over because
you know i never i never wanted to
return i i felt that
seven seasons what was it 167
hours of
series and i i had nothing else to say
with all done well
we have well thanks to our my
co-executive producers we found some
great story lines and great new
characters
well i want to follow up sir patrick on
the romance part because i watched the
episode whoopi goldberg is back in the
episode i love seeing her with you and
there's a great line in it which she
says she asks you what happened to your
heart because the only thing that you
seem to break is your bones and she
asked you so what has happened to your
heart how are you feeling about veering
into romance love territory i think it
would be great to see this on screen
gail the the the reason is that
he he no longer has employment he's not
he doesn't have a job
running his vineyards his chateau and
it gives him a chance to look around the
world and to share experiences
particularly with with uh
females that he's never had before and i
found that uh delightful and exciting of
course every time that i see whoopi i'm
falling in love all over again anyway so
that was perfectly straightforward to do
she has that effect on a lot of people
he does sir patrick there's a famous
story going back to your uh star trek
next generation days of the cast having
a good time you coming out of your
trailer uh and lecturing them and saying
we're not here to have fun uh you
lightened up considerably
and i know that that's a running joke
with your colleagues so i am curious
what was it like on this set any fun had
oh
so much fun we had a delightful group of
uh actors who enjoyed the work they did
and communicated that enjoyment to
everybody on the set
um yeah i was you know that was over 30
years ago and i was a different person
then i i didn't have fun fun wasn't on
my calendar as an actor but that has all
changed jonathan frakes who plays
commander riker of course now believes
that i am the most disruptive actor on
sometimes you have to be disruptive to
get your point across now you've done it
all from shakespeare to star trek
what's next for you
um
well uh again this is interesting having
just watched frank bruni i'm writing uh
i i am writing a memoir
and uh i'm 311 pages into it but there's
still about 100 to go so that's going to
be when
we
we stop shooting which we will in a few
days time
that's going to be my focus i'm shutting
myself away somewhere with sonny my wife
and i i'm just going to write for two or
three months because i have to finish
this and i've enjoyed it so much i've
never written before i didn't anticipate
wow
what fun it could be
well i hope you'll come here when it's
all done that you'll come here and i
hope there's heat in the van i hope you
enjoyed our luxurious accommodations for
you
thank you it has been indeed well you've
upgraded my status in my neighborhood
sir patrick stewart thank you so much
for joining us season two of star trek
picard premieres this thursday on our
streaming service paramount plus